dans un village qui jocke de la
frontière russe Katharina chefova
employé du parquet régional enquête sur
les crimes des forces russes la police
criminelle l'accompagne
une partie de ce sous-sol a été
transformée en cachot
c'est humide froid et l'odeur d'urine
est fort
les gens étaient gardés ici pour être
torturé
c'est pour cela que l'on respecte les
lieux avec les enquêteurs et les experts
ce n'est pas le seul lieu de Cosa
chalopan ou la torture était pratique
des tirs d'artillerie se font entendre
pas de quoi interrompre le travail des
enquêteurs
les enquêteurs sont actuellement en
train de relever différentes preuves ici
nous sommes dans le sous-sol d'une
station de train à 3 km seulement de la
frontière russe et les enquêteurs la
police le parquet de karky vont eu
l'information qu'ici et bien des
prisonniers étaient emmenés pour être
torturé par les forces russes de l'ADN
est relevé sur les objets situés dans le
sous-sol ils seront emmenés pour
expertise
pendant l'inspection on a trouvé du
scotch et on examine car ils sont sont
probablement servis pour attacher les
mains des victimes
ce sous-sol de la gare cet habitant qui
souhaite rester anonyme il y a passé
cinq jours avant d'être déplacé dans une
autre prison
ancien membre des Forces ukrainiennes
les soldats russes se sont acharnés sur
lui
l'un d'entre eux m'a interrogé sur mon
service et ma position dans l'armée il
m'a baissé le pantalon et le caleçon et
il m'a dit tu t'allonges si tout droit
il a pris une pince en fer il a accroché
à mon sexe
ils m'ont dit tu vas répondre
après cinq décharges électriques j'ai
essayé de me frapper la tête contre le
mur
je criais
c'était atroce
il se dit soulagé par la présence des
enquêteurs aujourd'hui soulagés mais
néanmoins détruit